I'm Jeremy Brock
welcome to the BAFTA and BFI
international screenwriters lecture
series for 2013 I was on the BAFTA Film
committee and discovered I was the only
screenwriter who'd ever been on it and
after I got over the shock I decided
that the best I could do for my
screenwriting brothers and sisters was
to set up a lecture series in the name
of BAFTA and we were able to bring the
BFI in on that this year we've got a
fantastic lineup we start with David s
Goyer we end with Richard Curtis and in
between we have Hossein Amini Susannah
grant and Tony Gilroy these are serious
heavyweights from the UK and from
America you will be inspired by these
individuals so now we have one of this
country's leading screenwriters so say
nomini there's a great skill in bringing
novels to film and Hoss has the ability
to marry his own voice and talent
invisibly to that of another author not
only to reduce the book to the film but
to make that translation really vivid
sitio film light drive incredibly visual
incredibly adept you think that's got to
be the camera that's got to be the
director actually when you look at the
screenplay and when you realize how much
of that's written that's what true
adaptation is and I would love it if
Haas was able to speak to that horse
it's a real privilege to have you on
this stage and I hope that we can
explore some of the secrets of the craft
through the conversation that we have
today and I thought what we do is start
actually with the opening of drive which
is a long sequence but I think the
audience is probably familiar with the
film and then look at how you structured
that afterwards
brilliant heist it would be easy to look
at that and say reviewer Direction good
storyboard work where's the writing well
it is a fantastic piece of directing I
think but I mean the reason what I want
to talk about this clip was because for
me a lot of screenwriting is in people's
perceptions of it is that it's all about
the dialogue and it the script that's a
seven page block of scene description
all those story beats were there and the
genesis of it was was that I went to to
meet the head of security at Universal
because they were commissioning it and
the first thing he said to me was
there's no way you can have a police
chase at the beginning because they'll
have helicopters in the moment they have
eyes on the car there's no point which
is where I think so few car chase movie
you know police chases really happened
these days and all the ones I've seen on
TV there's always aerial footage but
then that became a challenge so sort of
I went away and I thought well what if
it's a roof and he said yeah but they'll
just cover surround the building and
then I thought well what if there's a
crowd and also from that the thing that
came you know the idea was to set up
that so it started with a basketball
game at the Staples Center but then it's
also what was really fun about it was
how do you
you is mixing two pieces of sort of
sound writing really which is the
commentary of the the basketball game
but also the police radio going on at
the same time so all of these things
were scripted and then obviously
enhanced by a by Nicolas revenue
directed it but I think the point is
that there's there's so much visual
writing I think you know for any
screenwriter and I think some that's
sometimes something that we're not given
credit for and and it's a sort of I I
love writing in pictures and and and and
lots of pages without dialogue so I mean
that's really where I wanted to start
with something like this
and it really started with the gut the
security guy and that's the thing it
wasn't I can't even say it started with
me it start with a person who sort of
went all that's impossible
yeah and it sort of so I think I think
the whole thing is incredible you know
incredibly collaborative and that's part
of the fun and I think the research for
me is all the most important bits and
this was this was really something that
came out of research and then the other
thing I remember doing was I don't
actually drive so I didn't tell my to
film my driving test seven times
I did tell Nicholas Ruffin who's the
director at then in every interview he
gave afterwards he said that he'd felt
at eight times so I'm sure there's a
little bit of competition going on but
the point was so what I did is I bought
myself a map of LA and and almost
planned the route as well so so all of
these little stages were all kind of
scripted I think the research was also a
very important part of that particular
sequence and it's something I love doing
and the silent hero the Ryan Gosling
driver character is that is that the
kind of hero you like to write know that
was that there was a there was a
fabulous book it was it didn't really
have the same storyline but it had this
fantastic central character and and when
I read the book it immediately reminded
me the idea of the man with no name who
comes into the sort of you know comes
into the the small village and saves
everyone and then leaves and no one
knows who he is so it's very much
sort of using films I loved as well I
mean that's why I enjoyed there's so
much was it was it was it was her
cannibalizing other movies but also
there was a beautiful book and it was a
chance to do you know film la which is a
genre I've always really loved I noticed
the book doesn't begin with this heist
and drive sequence it begins with
something else altogether I knew that
that there's quite a lot of setup before
you get to the action in the movie and
and university of had originally sort of
written it for with the studio you sort
of can't hang around that they sort of
want to see the action beads so in order
to buy myself thirty pages where I could
to spend on character and sort of
establishing driver in the love story I
knew I had to have sort of seven pages
action at the beginning and when you get
or when you got a commission like this
were you were the first person on there
was no director attached no actor
what was the Commission take the book
and do what you want with it or was
there a direction in the Steven mission
was stunt driver by day getaway driver
by night which is a great catchphrase
and I'm sure they've that was already
sort of gonna be what was on the poster
but it was an incredibly dark book which
is very unusual for a studio it's a
Commission which is why jumped at the
chance because it was sort of getting
paid a studio rate to do something
fantastic like that but they didn't like
the first or the second draft and it was
eventually put in turn around and became
a much much smaller independent movie
and to what extent did the process of
bringing on a director and the casting
of Ryan Gosling effect the evolved the
evolving nature in the screenplay and
what you mean writing Oh Nicholas ref
indeed which is which was for me was a
terrific kind of way to work was he just
we had a hundred and twenty odd page
scripts started off with and then he
said look I haven't got enough money to
shoot this I don't have enough days to
get it done so let's just cut it down
and that's all we did we didn't really
add very much
it was really just this thing I've taken
the script and and I think it was
something like 90 89 pages by the end of
it so it was almost like working with an
editor in a cutting room where where
we're just going through the other thing
he did which I absolutely loved was was
made me sit down with each of the actors
from the smallest parts to Ryan and
spend a whole day just going through
what they thought about the character
you know the changes he was very very he
was very comfortable leaving me alone
with the actors and and that was a
process that I really enjoyed and I sort
of found and I sort of found
subsequently and is something I'd love
to be able to keep doing is is working
with actors once the script has got to a
certain stage because I think they have
certain insights ideas and ultimately
they're the people who have to say those
lines so I've become much less Precious
about nailing the dialogue in draft one
or two because I know that at some stage
they're going to come on and they're
going to want changes and it's got to
fit their patterns of delivery and and
it's great to be part of that process
well we're going to come back to drive
but actually I'd like to go right back
to one of the first things you wrote at
least your first feature film which is
Jude and if we look at the clip that
we've picked from Jude will notice two
of our finest actors quite early on in
their careers Kate Winslet and Chris
Eccleston but perhaps you could set it
up for us
it's basically Juden sue who
who have had a terrible tragedy happen
in their life and she feels incredibly
guilty about what's happened and in this
scene he tries to persuade her to to
come back to him and then see what
happens you have to listen to me come
home no I can't
it's alright you told I know what to do
I have to go back to Richard in the
morning
you go to write to Arabella ask her to
take me mag thing to us still married
you you and I married do you care for
him do you love him I'll learn to love
him how can you so you love me you love
me sooo much there hmm what sort of
process did you have to go through to
reduce it to what we see and I see all
of those scenes pretty much exist I
think that's about five or six pages and
it's all dialogue in the book so most of
the dialogue there is from the book but
it's it's obviously just completely
filtered down which was the process you
know particularly in adapting dude that
I had to do is the first it was the
first book I adapted and I sort of had
this system of going through it on ik on
cards writing down every single scene
then you know going through the cards
and getting rid of some inventing new
scenes very very rarely where I just
needed to make links and and that was
it's probably only adaptation I've done
where I've I've sort of been used the
book because normally what I do actually
the other books I've done they've tended
not to have scenes or being very
different from what the screenplays
ended up but with with Jude because it's
such a linear story and with with these
very well crafted scenes and stuff it
was a quest of choosing and unfortunate
to lose stuff and it was definitely more
craft than anything else because I think
I think the Hardys had done so much of
of the work narratively that it was
really about trying to shape it it's
interesting I mean you wrote this nearly
20 years ago if you were to take on
something like Jude now would you
approach it differently or would that be
the same um process I don't know that
I'd try to adapt Jude if I was I mean
that the reason at the time I was as
fact it was it was literally the only
thing I'd been offered that was was a
feature films I would have done anything
really would have done I didn't and I
remember my agent name asked me who
still made and he sort of he told me
this had come up and he and and the
Michael wants to know if I'd read it and
I'd lied and said I had I absolutely
hadn't read it and because it's the
first film I sort of paid it a lot more
attention and I remember standing
outside I said I'm just seeing how it
was our opening night and seeing how and
everyone would come up to you know to
buy their tickets and I'd overhear
people saying oh that got good dude got
quite good reviews think I'll know it
specially really depressing let's go and
see the Nutty Professor and everyone you
know and I can kind of understand it
because it was on a Friday night and one
of the problems I've had is I sort of
all of my film kind of falling in love
with film experiences happened on Monday
afternoons and people you know go to the
cinema partly you know largely for
entertainment and I think it's certainly
not entertaining and it sort of there
are other ways we kind of you know have
that intellectual stimulation and then
and it sort of and I'd look I'd still
love to write something I'm very proud
of it but I do question its commercial
validity in an industry where you have
to make money in order to justify doing
the next thing and then it's a lot of
money to make a film how much of
yourself do you put into your into your
work I put all my tastes in it I think
that's why I'll probably the next thing
I'll do is going to be just as dark and
depressing as that and that you the only
ones I've been able to to do which
aren't like that and have some sort of
commercial thing of when I've been doing
rewrites on studio movies after Jude and
the success of Jude you got the label
for being the period man and that the
guy who could adapt our classics in a
interesting and original way and perhaps
we could go on to talk about what you
put in of yourself two wings of a dove
and maybe you could set up the first
pitch voice so this is the same way that
the story is really about these two
these two lovers who conspire to they
befriend this sick dying girl and sort
of think by
the woman who was played by Ana bottom
cast who is not in this thing the latest
seem convinces her boyfriend played by
Linus Roache to seduce Milly the dying
girl and said that she will leave him
and therefore them her money at the end
what happens is he starts to really fall
in love with her and in this scene she's
found out their plot and he goes to try
to tell her that it's not that he never
meant to kind of hasser and stuff like
that so it's really it's his apology
feel better in the mornings such a big
city but you might see you wandering
around I thought the same where did you
go San Marco the Rialto all the places
we went together maybe we just kept
missing each other we turning the corner
just to see you with you I've thought of
that so I stayed in the same place and
waited for hours
and we still didn't see each other when
we go back to London I'm not going
anywhere what we do here
same things we did before do I look like
I can climb a church scaffold you can do
anything you want
honey I believe him when he said he
stood in one spot and waited for hours
well no that was that was actually
something that happened to me I there
was um I had I'd been in Venice I went
quite a few times as a student because
it the book the book is the Henry James
but there aren't really any scenes in it
everything sort of reported off-screen
so it's for example that scene there's
there's there's no scene written you
just hear from somebody else that Merton
went and confessed to many as far as I
remember so it was it made it really
exciting to adapt because it was in a
way it was it was a everyone sort of
thought that you know the later Henry
James from novels were unadaptable which
sort of took some of the pressure off
and and because they weren't they
weren't some they weren't really scenes
like I felt free to kind of invent them
both with Drive and wings that have even
though very few of the scenes in the
book in the screenplay exist in the book
what both writers James honest you know
and Henry James do is just create these
extraordinary characters that are so
brilliantly described that actually you
sort of become it becomes very easy to
to write dialogue for them even if that
dialogue doesn't exist in the books
because they're so well defined and you
know so much about them that there's it
sort of flows and it's it's it's really
it's their writing not me I just sort of
feel that you know the characters are so
well drawn seeing the way the lines fits
so comfortably in the mouths of actors
and hearing you talk about Nick Griffin
and the experience with drive I just
wondered whether we should cue the last
clip does the in order to give you an
obvious talk about actors I think we
would have made a go with this business
don't worry don't worry that's it it's
done there's no pain it's all for its
own
that scene was completely inspired by it
something I've always I was reading in
it's a Hitchcock quote about filming
your love scenes like it like murders
and your murders like love scenes and
then the scene afterwards obviously it's
like he's almost morning
like he's broken up with someone that's
a was that idea of you know that these
these sort of men almost in love around
you know ending up killing each other
that's what there was just something
very been that that was again a scene
that's not in in the book but was
inspired by these two great characters
and who are in the book and did did they
cast themselves bring anything yes it's
really um this was going back to what
Nicholas said he made him make me sit
down I mean he'd be he'd get off
location scouting and I'd be left with
him saying I don't like my scene I
didn't like my line so he was safe so
originally the way the scene had been
written was that Bernie Rose comes to
hug him and stabs him and Brian Cranston
was kind of going and that sounds like a
painful way to kill someone you should
believe you know you like apparently
it's painless if you you know slash the
wrists and I don't know if that's true
or not but it certainly sounded good and
he seemed pretty convinced so that idea
came from him and I'm sort of sitting
there listening and thinking oh that's
kind of interesting so then I'd go away
the next day and right and quite quite
often it was it was it's very privileged
position to be a writer in an actor's
rehearsal and even more so in a case
like this where you were sort of almost
you know leading the rehearsals ends up
they're talking and you're kind of
taking ideas in terms of how to write
the scene and and it does bring me back
to the point that I think writers are
quite often the most important or
potentially the best collaborators for
for screenwriters and quite often the
most valuable notes I've heard have been
from actors I mean really interesting is
they like um like what their first line
is is they
need I sort of found that they need a
strong first line to sort of define them
to help them play the part and I sort of
found it very very interesting and
useful just to follow their instincts in
the later stages of the script when the
structural work has been done and the
scenes have their shape brings me to
another point which is quite often
actors will claim that they rewrote the
scene or or whatever which is true to a
certain extent but it bit but I think
and I think every writer will say this
is you wouldn't have been able to write
it if the scene hadn't have been there
in the first place and everything all
all you know the blocks are there for
them and then I think it's fine to let
them kind of riff and change line here
or there because it's it's the shape is
there in the shape isn't gonna change
that much I suppose it's the same thing
with pace as well you can suggest the
pace but you can't dictate it you can't
dictate pace but I mean sort of being a
sneaky writer you can try to manipulate
like the person with pauses and I love
pauses because I think generally I like
I like the reactions to a line that's
said probably more than the line
sometimes so what I'll tend to do is is
is write a line in between two lines of
dialogue and they're usually really bad
because as she stares out or he reflects
or something like that but it's sort of
but it's still sort of creating a sort
of rhythm now whether they the director
sort of sticks to that that's that's
that's really up to them but but you try
to do it or you start a scene by writing
describing I mean I don't like doing
close up on lamp or whatever but by
starting with what you want the first
shot of the film to do so if you
describe that lamp
there's slim chance that the director
might start it like that well I'm gonna
have to show you with the audience but
before I do that I will just take lead
from that note from you and ask you how
you have found it directing because
you're in post-production on your
directorial debut which is you directing
yourself as a writer adapting Patricia
Highsmith and perhaps you can tell us
what you know I mean things like I mean
it's part of that that's I think
something I'd recommend to any writer is
to spend time in a cutting room
because you learn so many things that
how long a scene usually can be what
goes out coming in in the middle of a
scene hammer you know and all those but
beyond that there's also like on once
you're faced with problems that as a
director that you caused yourself as a
writer so there are bits where I had
arrived three long dialogue scenes
back-to-back and I'll probably do it
again but I swear right now that I'll
try not to because it's sort of in the
cutting room you find you know the thing
I'd always underestimate is how
important momentum is and that's
something you really learn in the
cutting room more than you do on the
page because when you're writing a
script to a reading a script you can go
back and forth and it doesn't bore you
once it's shot it becomes this sort of
one and a half hour two hour train and
it's just moving so for example I learnt
that you can start the film as a drama
if it then turns into a thriller in it's
sort of next 10 pages or whatever I
think it's very tough for an audience to
then go back to the pace of a drama
again so I think you can I mean
drive just about gets away with it but
but it's still it's still you know that
whole thinking about how an audience is
going to spend those two hours and
that's that's quite a big leap from the
page when you're writing a screenplay to
imagining the finished film in terms of
its pace and rhythm and momentum but
it's something I real that's what I
realized how important in structure and
and and momentum and and balancing of
action scenes with dialogue scenes or
Thrillist suspense scenes with with
character scenes and and it's it's
thinking about those combinations I
think is really important something I
certainly learn really from difficulties
in the cutting room can we have some
hands for questions from the audience
you mentioned research with Dr do you
feel it's problematic when you come to
something there you only you have
experience of I think I think it's it's
problematic but but you do I mean if
you're if you're at the moment you
agreed to adapt a book there's obviously
something in it that's touched you and
and it touches you because it's it hits
some personal note so I think I think
there is that response so that's that
that and the research can only really
sort of help that nor meant it but it's
sort of the most important thing for me
sort of in adapting a book it is really
that there's a feeling when you read a
book and I'm sure everyone here has had
it where you get so immersed and you
enjoy it so much that you feel that
nobody else has read the book like
you've read the book if you were to meet
your younger you say when you were 18
what advice would you give to yourself
I'd say don't sign exclusive deals for
you I had a very long exclusive deal
with with Miramax sort of and it was it
was an odd deal because it was I sort of
realized that there that the films that
I wanted to do weren't necessary the
films they wanted to do and I ended up
doing quite a lot of rewrites and stuff
for them and I learnt an incredible
amount because it is it's it's you're
suddenly thrown into things that you
wouldn't necessarily choose so you're
having to I think the craft gets
stronger I mean because you're having to
you know to learn how to make things
work that don't necessarily work for you
I just couldn't work for anyone else so
there was an opportunity for example to
work on on Munich student Spielberg film
which I would have you know really loved
to have been involved in but because I
was exclusive to Miramax I wasn't
allowed to you know just having done a
sound mix now for the first time I'm
sort of learning so much about nothing
well I can go back to the writing or or
something that the an editor I've
brilliant editor that I've worked with
made me do with with with the film and
directed was to cut it into three short
films as it were so following each
character and it's something I'd
probably go back and do with scripts is
like if I want to unlock something is
take one characters journey and what all
it means is taking out the scenes that
they're not in so to see is that
characters you know is it consistent is
their line is their story within
the overall script consistent is it
moving is it this and and that's
something I learned from an editor in an
editing room and I think I think you can
learn so much from other people in the
industry and I sort of wish I'd I sort
of befriended more people and kind of
just sort of found you know more people
to sort of teach me and that gentleman
over there really is the last question
just here I'm interested in the process
how about do you follow the same rhythm
each day do you start at a certain time
stop at a certain time start by doing a
certain thing rereading what you did
yesterday or I'm just generally
interested in how that was i've got
completely city that can lay it out it
sort of generally starter around 7:30
7:30 8:00 maybe right till about 1 or 2
because I find the only thing I write
after that I just end up rewriting the
same line again and again so I stop I
stop writing but then what I'll do is
I'll kind of prepped for the next day so
I'll either read research something
around the scene I'm writing or watch a
movie which is somehow related to the
scene I'm writing the next day and and
try to stay in in some sort of zone
because it said I can't do more than one
script at a time for that reason I just
sort of needed quite immersed and I need
to stay the mercenary fight I can be a
bit of a pain at home because I'd sort
of like you know you know if I'm if I've
got a big scene to write I don't really
want to go out to a party and get drunk
and and because I need you know so I
sort of it's almost like some sort of
that weird exercise to try to be ready
and I'm sorry we can't invite you back
tomorrow night to go through a regular
session of how you do what you do but
thank you so much for sharing your
secrets
you